hey everyone it's sarah with  registerednessrn.com and in this video  i'm going to demonstrate how to assess  the crawling reflex in a newborn  it's also sometimes called bower  crawling reflex  and how you get a response out of an  infant with this is that you place them  on their stomach  and you apply pressure with your hand to  the sole  of the foot so whenever you do this the  infant will attempt to push against thy  hand with their foot  and move the arms and legs in a crawling  like motion  and this tends to disappear anywhere  between a few weeks after birth  to a couple months okay so that wraps up  this video on how to assess the crawling  reflex in a newborn and be sure to check  out the other reflex videos in this  series